- [Interviewer] I shoot so many.
I only use about one out of six,
one out of five or six that I shoot.
So there's all day, I'll shoot things,
and sometimes I don't use anything.
- It's good to see you today.
- [Interviewer] It's nice to see you.
- Yeah.
It's been like, oh, crazy, crazy, crazy.
Oh my god.
Things in my life, you know?
Anyhow, let me do this.
- [Interviewer] Go ahead, do your thing.
(crackling)
That's all you need?
Just a little hit like that.
- I'm cool.
- What does crack do for you?
- What does it do for me?
Most of the time,
well, now that I'm older,
actually this whole last little run,
god, I've been smoking it a lot though
for like steady since 2015.
You know what I mean?
Now, it's 2020.
Oh my god.
But I got out of prison.
It was the last time I got out.
That was after I got out.
When I went in, it was 2013 in May.
And I was told my mom passed away.
And then the very next week,
the seven year joint
suspended sentence was imposed
'cause I didn't have a piece of paper
saying I completed the program
although I did, how do you say,
over the amount of days.
It was a 90 day program,
I did 114 days, you know?
But I didn't have that
paper, which was like crazy.
But anyhow, so the following week,
that was imposed.
And then the next week, I was
in prison mourning my mom.
And I didn't know that she
had dementia, you know?
And I didn't find out until I was on AR,
you know, the receiving yard.
That's the receiving yard at Chowchilla.
And when it was explained to me,
I was thinking of my headphone worms.
I always got my headphones all the time.
Gotta have my music, got to.
- [Interviewer] So, Doreen,
where'd you grow up?
Where are you from?
- From the valley, San Fernando Valley.
There's only one the valley.
- Yes, there is.
- Only one.
And I hate when people say, "What valley?"
There's only one.
It's like, oh my god, like totally,
you know what I mean?
- [Interviewer] What
was your childhood like?
- Huh?
- [Interviewer] What
was your childhood like?
- I was very quiet.
I was very quiet, quiet.
I didn't talk a lot at all.
Very quiet.
I remember even when I first
was on Columbus Street,
you know, which is off of Sepulveda,
that was the infamous
drive-thru, you know, crack,
get your ready rock, you know what I mean?
Back in, let me see, it was like,
I got on Sepulveda, it was '88, '88.
'87 is when I first started smoking crack.
It was actually not crack then.
It was cocaine powder.
And that was in Northridge, you know?
You know, real rock house.
The true blue, you know,
true blue rock house.
You know, everybody's just smoking.
- [Interviewer] You had
mom and dad as a kid?
- No.
My father passed away when I
was five and a half weeks old.
He named me Doreen, which means gift,
derives from the Greek word,
dorea, which means gift.
And he named me.
My mom had no choice in it,
you know, my name.
I'm Greek.
You know my great-grandparents
from my father side
came from Greece,
from Sparta and someplace called Malta.
I can't even begin to figure
that pronunciation out,
but it was Southern Greece.
- [Interviewer] How was your childhood?
- How was it?
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- I was safe, secure.
My mom was a heroin addict.
I remember when I was two,
she put me and my older
sister in foster care.
A real nice house, I
remember that very well.
The lady grew spinach
on the side of the house
and I love vegetables.
I mean, pacify me with vegetables.
Forget a sucker or forget ice cream,
sort of all that stuff.
Just a bowl of string beans.
My mom did that once.
A bowl of string beans.
I was like, I'm not going to stop crying.
I just remember saying that, you know,
and that's how I was in
eating that whole bowl.
I wasn't crying no more.
- [Interviewer] So, you started
using drugs at what age?
- 17 and a half.
It was late August of 1987.
I told my mom I wanted to try it.
She's like, okay, you know what I mean?
And I tried it and I
was like 10 second high.
I was like, forget that,
you know what I mean?
I'd rather get high on acid
and be high for like 15 hours,
you know what I mean?
You know, 'cause I'd tried
acid at that time too,
like five hits, like total, you know?
And I don't know, it
didn't really appeal to me.
You know, I didn't
really, really get into it
until I went to this house.
It was like sitting
around the kitchen table
and it was like huge
kitchen table all night
and just smoking.
And before I got left out the front door,
I remember just puking.
That's how much I smoked, you know?
I just threw up, you know?
And pretty much from there on,
I was smoking every day.
- [Interviewer] Since you were a teenager?
- Mm-hmm, since 17 and a half.
Yeah, 'cause May, June, July, August.
Actually, I was barely 17.
- [Interviewer] And where's
that taken your life?
- Prison.
A lot of time.
I've done a lot of time.
Prostituting to support my habit.
I actually made a decision to prostitute
instead of rob people or rob places,
you know what I mean?
Or sell drugs, you know?
- [Interviewer] How has
that decision affected you?
Has it changed the way you view men?
Has it made your life more dangerous?
Has it done anything?
- I don't know.
It's created, you know,
I don't know.
It's like a good and a bad.
- [Interviewer] What
are the goods and bads?
- The good is that I got to
be able to experiment more
'cause I was always seeking the sensation,
the feeling sexually.
I was molested when I was 13.
It was my mom's boyfriend
and he just asked to go down on me.
And he told me, I could say no.
You know, he made me
feel very comfortable,
I mean, very comfortable.
And I'm the most sensitive girl
out of my mom's three daughters, you know?
I mean we had to celebrate
or acknowledge every holiday,
every single one, you know?
And for me to feel so comfortable,
even now to this day, you know,
it was like a light switch.
You know what I mean? Like
you don't even think about it.
When it's off, it's off,
and you just walk away.
You never have another lingering
attached thought to it.
You know?
And I have full control,
you know what I mean?
I have full control.
And I'm the one
that actually initiated the
intercourse part, you know?
And it never hurt.
It took him eight times
before it actually went all the way in,
got all the way.
When I said stop, he stopped,
literally just stopped right there
as soon as I said, stop, you know?
I even hid from my own mother.
When she would come home,
you know what I mean?
We'd be scrambling, you know what I mean,
to get dressed and stuff.
- [Interviewer] And you were how old?
- I was 13 and it went on until I was 17.
I was 17.
That guy, man,
that man just really drastically
affected every single woman in that home.
You know? 'Cause my mom had got a home.
The first mortgage was paid by Cecil.
You know, that was the contract
that my mother made with him
for starting the business,
that and getting a Corvette,
but she didn't end up
getting the Corvette.
She got another car.
And we got a brand new house up in Acton.
It was a really nice ass house,
but my mom didn't like it
'cause there was mice up there.
So we went back to the house on Longridge,
6327 Longridge Avenue.
And so that's basically where I grew up.
Even though my mom
started using heroin again
when she got with this man,
she always provided a safe, secure place.
You know what I mean?
Clean, always food.
I never seen my mom slam ever.
You know, I knew what she did.
I had no worries in that area, you know?
But everything that she tried
to like sequester me from
was in the family, you know what I mean?
Drugs, being molested, all that, violence,
you know, everything
was pretty much there.
I don't know.
But I don't know,
in anyway, I guess, I
had a good childhood.
I had a good childhood even though,
even so, I had a good childhood.
I knew my mommy loved me.
I had no doubt of that.
That was for sure.
Never had a doubt.
She didn't even have to say it.
Shoot, I grew up as a middle child,
but an only child
'cause she sent both my
sisters somewhere else to live
when she started using again
'cause she had a hysterectomy.
That's what she says
triggered her to use again,
but it wasn't.
It was 'cause she was with that guy
and he was using, you know?
And so eventually it's gonna
affect, you know what I mean?
But anyhow, so when I started using,
I got arrested.
My first time I got arrested
was on Roscoe and Sepulveda.
And they got me for under the influence,
paraphernalia, possession,
spitting at a cop, and false information.
I spit at the cop 'cause I was underage.
You know what I mean?
I had one of those cutouts shirts,
you know that the muscle
shirts. I didn't have no bra on
and it kept falling off
'cause I was handcuffed.
I was trying to ask them to put it up
to where it wouldn't
keep falling, you know?
And they wouldn't.
And they were making lewd comments,
the police officers as they
were going by in the station.
So I spit at one of the cops.
I was like, you know.
Anyhow, so that's the charge
I had gotten, you know?
And then pretty much from there,
I never knew,
god, I wish I would have never
tried smoking cocaine ever
'cause once you know,
you know you can never go back from,
you can never go back to not knowing,
you know what I mean?
You can't.
Once you know, you know.
- [Interviewer] So today,
you're living on Skid Row?
- Yeah, 'cause I ran away from the valley.
I ran away from Sepulveda.
Sepulveda used to drive
me crazy literally.
I've gotten all my time there.
- [Interviewer] Sepulveda was drugs,
and prostitution, and just the rough life.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And coming down here,
what do you gain by
coming down to Skid Row?
- Well, I got off parole,
got off probation.
I've met a lot of great people.
I mean, the people out
here are extraordinary.
Every single one of
them are extraordinary.
The women out here,
a good I would say 80% of the
women right here in this area
especially on the bottom side,
I've known for many years, decades,
because we've done time
throughout the years, you know?
And so I've always known
them without getting high
and they've always known me as quiet,
playing bridge, you know what I mean?
And I've been like really like
way out out here, you know,
but it's been experience.
I would have never thought.
I've been boisterous, very
boisterous, very loud boisterous.
There was a point where actually,
I couldn't even stop myself from talking.
And that had to do with my mom's,
my mom going through the dementia.
It really affected me,
psychologically affected me, you know?
'Cause she wouldn't let
me get like one sentence,
barely even half a sentence
completed, you know?
And like I said,
I didn't have no idea what she was,
that she had dementia and what it does.
I had no idea until after
she passed away, you know?
And I actually chose to
come here specifically,
right here in Skid Row to mourn my mother
with people that at least
knew my face, you know?
And then they've gotten to
know me and care about me.
They really do care.
They really truly care a lot.
You know, damn.
They've gotten to know
me just by observing me,
just by observing me, you know?
I have a lot of love and care out here,
which is so crazy 'cause the one,
the man that I love a lot,
oh my god.
What I've been through with
him is just extreme, extreme.
Never in my life have I given
so much monetarily wise.
Yeah, just so much.
But you know, I've been
hard on him too in ways.
I can't really (indistinct) exactly,
but we pretty much just like
put each other through the wringer
and are still kind of doing it,
but I don't know.
I'm still there, you know?
I don't know.
He's, I don't know.
He ready to give up, you
know what I mean, and go.
I don't know what I'd do
without him, you know?
It won't be the same.
I won't feel as safe neither.
I felt very okay before he
came into my life, you know?
I didn't have no worries, you know?
And I knew who was who, what's what,
and who to associated with,
who not to associate with,
but I talk to everybody
no matter what, you know?
No matter what, you know?
I got a rapport with
just about everybody here
as far as the men are
concerned on a one-on-one.
We have an individual rapport, you know?
And because of that,
that has kept me safe from harm.
The women, shoot, they just know who I am.
You know what I mean?
They don't trip on me at all.
You know?
- [Interviewer] How do
you think all these years
of living this lifestyle has changed you?
Can you imagine a different Doreen
if you hadn't taken to
drugs, and prostitution,
and this whole street life thing?
- You know, downtown, Skid
Row and being down here
is what's really changed me a lot.
Being down here,
my experiences down here
has really changed me a lot.
From leaving the sober living home, man.
I was really okay, you know what I mean?
I was really okay.
I felt pretty, you know what I mean?
I was a self-okay, you know what I mean?
I didn't need outside things, you know?
I really didn't, you know?
I had everything I needed
as far as monetarily wise
and I had just enough back pay
to be able to put the down
payment on an apartment.
You know what I mean?
The move in costs, you know, just enough.
It was like 1,500, you know?
It was just barely enough, you know?
And why use?
My period.
See, I've had like this whole thing
all through my life, right?
And when I got Melissa,
I know that something
like shut down in my head,
but I didn't really
realize until just recently
really how much it affected me.
I mean, this really affects
me really hard, you know?
And for me to reach and obtain
that feeling to be fucked by a man,
you know what I mean,
just like as a woman,
you know what I mean?
That whole feeling and not just coming,
but having an orgasm, which
is completely different.
Like I've had an orgasm,
but it was like giving
my baby's father head.
You know what I mean?
He's like, you gotta
come back down to earth.
You gotta come back down 'cause
you're like up, you know?
That's the only way I can explain it.
But I want to feel that sensation,
having intercourse, you know what I mean?
And the man that I'm with now,
he's been able to attain
a certain state of it,
but, shoot, that's why I was like,
I've always been able to experiment
and seek, you know what I mean?
And just like, you
know, test this and that
because of the choice I had
made to prostitute, you know?
I've had much experience, you know?
Had different men, you know,
in different things, in
different situations.
One thing I've come to
learn is that my chemistry,
that one hormone that gets this release
when a woman goes on her period,
it's like the second or
third day, it's more.
It's the highest, highest release.
I learned that.
When I was at Amity,
I finally got to the point where like,
at that time, I was like fuck it.
Why start?
I'm just gonna get disappointed,
you know what I mean?
It's gonna be the same thing, you know?
So I'm not even gonna begin, you know?
Fuck it, you know?
'Cause I've been through, you know,
I mean, many experiences
where I've had guys that really wanted to,
you know what I mean,
take that time and everything,
you know, and really cool.
And I got along with them
and there was like something there,
you know what I mean?
And 'cause there's gotta
be something there.
That's first and foremost
one thing I learned.
I gotta have some type of
feeling towards the man,
some kind of something has
gotta be there for me to feel.
And then it was a chemistry
thing that I learned next.
And then the third thing,
the biggest thing was if I choose.
I chose to be with a guy, Oscar.
It wasn't 'cause of anything
that he said that he could do
or anything like that.
It didn't have anything to do with him,
or what he wanted, or
might want, or whatever,
which, man, that just
like opened a whole door
like completely different
where like I felt every
touch when he touched me.
I felt each touch fully, you know?
It wasn't really the sensation
that as far as vaginally,
but the touches I felt.
And I realized there's choice
and choosing, really choosing, you know?
Not having control,
but choosing to be with
somebody because I want to,
not because they want to or might like to,
whatever, you know?
And so that was cool, you know?
And then there's, with me,
you gotta be able to
reach each part of me.
Here.
If you don't care, you
gotta care about me.
There's gotta be some kind of care, love.
You gotta reach my soul,
you know, pretty much.
Got to.
Otherwise, I won't.
The guy that I'm with now, Gary,
you know, I don't even like
anybody touching my titties
'cause they're so sensitive, you know?
And I like him to touch them.
I like him to go down on me.
I don't like that, you know what I mean,
'cause of being molested.
And plus, I don't really
get anything from it.
You know what I mean?
She's a hard case.
There's a little girl still, you know?
She's trying to grow up,
but she'd be like shutting
down on me, you know?
And she's like, no, no, no, no, no,
I'm not gonna, you know?
Like a little girl, you know?
And even I have a hard time, you know?
Like just last night,
I was gonna go ahead
and do it in the shower
'cause I can get myself off.
I've learned different ways where I can
and different sensations,
but really to get the release,
you know, like coming,
that kind of release,
it's in the shower with water, you know?
And I just figured that one out
because I heard the girls over.
They'd been locked up talking
about the water, you know?
I was like, okay.
Well, I tried it once and it worked,
you know what I mean?
And so it's changed over the years,
but now, it's like it's so
hard to get it sometimes
'cause it's like one very
specific spot, you know?
And I don't know if that's just
because how I'm made down there or what,
you know, I don't know.
You know, there was one time.
There was one time I was in the motel
and I was with this guy named Walter.
He was like the roly poly
(indistinct) with glasses
'cause he smoked crack.
You know what I mean?
But he's like, I've met many men,
but he's the only man
that I've really met,
man, you know?
'Cause he couldn't envision me
going out to go sell my body
to provide a roof over my
head at the motel I was at.
When he realized I was gonna go do that,
oh no, he wouldn't let
me, you know what I mean?
And therefore, he went and
put his life in jeopardy.
He was robbing Ralph's, you know,
and he would really get 'em good.
And he provided more than I could
ever provide for myself, you know?
And there was this one time.
Wait, there was this one time.
And it was like three weeks
before we even did anything sexually.
And we didn't really do it all the way.
It was like, we were like little
kids too at the same time.
It was very intimate,
very intimate and open.
He didn't even indicate by an eyelash,
one of his eyelashes that
he was interested in me.
And I'd be walking around
butt naked, you know?
Which men can't really handle
that from me I've learned.
I've learned what if about
myself as far as my beauty
in another way down here
in Skid Row from the men,
you know?
Even the women have confided
in me in certain ways
and told me certain things.
Walter, the one that I says
is the only man that I
have ever really met.
'Cause I asked him, what is it about me?
You know what I mean?
Like, what is it, you know?
He's like, "Everybody wants Deedee."
That's my nickname in the valley.
Everybody wants Deedee.
I'm like, "What do you mean, everyone?"
He said, "Even the girls want Deedee."
I'm like, "No." He's like,
"Why are you with me?"
You know, he couldn't understand it.
He could not understand, you know?
And it's not about.
I don't go after physical.
Your physique doesn't matter to me.
Money doesn't matter to me.
You can't get me that way.
You know, you can't even
give me that with crack.
You know, if I choose to,
it's 'cause I choose to.
I really have to choose
to, you know what I mean?
And the guys learned
that about me down here
that that's something different about me.
I do have certain morals
and ethics no matter what.
Crack don't change that, you know?
'Cause I'm me, you know,
I'm who I am and will always be.
(knocking on door)
Hello?
- [Interviewer] I think that's Amanda.
- It's been so exciting down here.
I want to write a book.
- [Interviewer] Hold on one second.
- Okay, okay, okay.
Amanda?
It's okay.
Come here, (indistinct).
What do you need?
(indistinct)
Need some money for (indistinct)?
Tell you what, (indistinct)
give you some money,
but try not to spend it on you know what.
Do you know what I mean?
- [Amanda] All right, thank you.
(faint speaking)
- [Interviewer] Amanda,
she's a wild animal.
She's a wild animal.
- Which one is that, Amanda?
- [Interviewer] Amanda,
the young Black girl
that's kind of just like.
She walks around like shoeless.
She's schizophrenic,
so she has like serious problems.
And then she's doing crack
cocaine like a fiend,
so that combination's bad.
- I love these girls down here.
I admire the women down here.
When I've thought about it and I realize,
you know, these women,
they've been through
some really scary stuff
because it used to be
completely different down here.
I used to hear the stories
down here from them
and it was really treacherous
and hard on these women.
- [Interviewer] Terrible.
- And they still stand tall
and they still are who they are.
They're in or out.
'Cause I knew them sober mostly.
I know them without doing drugs mostly
and they're the same
individuals, you know?
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
And they've been through hell
and they never talk about it
except when they come in this little room.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] But generally,
these people just are
existing with all this damage
and all this terrible.
- I have such admiration.
I look up to these women.
I look up to each and
every single one of them.
The ones that people look down on,
I still look up to them, you know?
And I wish I could so much, you know,
be able to have that kind
of strength, endurance,
self-recognition, you know what I mean?
That men and what they may do
or the environment and what may happen
has not destroyed that in them.
You know?
And you know, we truly are
God's people down here,
God and heaven's people right here.
Very cherished by him and I know this.
- [Interviewer] All right, Doreen.
Thank you so much.
Thank you so much for sharing your story.
- It's great to be here though.
It really is great to be
here even on the worst days.
It's part of life.
Humanity part, you know?
- [Interviewer] Thank you very much.
- God bless.
God bless everybody and I love everybody.
I really do, I really do.
- [Interviewer] That was great.
It was much better than the last one.
- [Doreen] Thank you.
I was stumbling a little bit.
- [Interviewer] No,
you're a great speaker.
- [Doreen] Yeah?
I scored low mark (indistinct).
- [Interviewer] No, no, no, no.
Everyone has a different
style of communicating.
- [Doreen] I've used very insane words.
I use very basic words.